hello everyone
welcome back
let's throw me on
[Music]
anyways this week we'll go over fixing
audio issues you might have with your
sound and how you can go about
repairing it in post-production so what
kind of problems are we talking about
well getting wind noise uh airplanes or
cars audio signals being too low or too
weak uh using a poor low quality
microphone that's a nice microphone ones
that's not plugged in so before you
apply any filters mixes or anything
complicated you need to edit your sound
edit it the first step is to organize
your track the first step is to
organizing your tracks if a problem
happens in one track likely it's
happening more than once throughout it
take a look at our mixing video for more
tips on how to organize all your audio
organize organize
the simplest method to cover issues is
to go through scene by scene and find
any issues like bumps pops cracks
anything that needs to be removed go
ahead and cut them out and replace them
with some room tone or empty air be
creative professional tips at the end of
most of your lines and edits you'll want
to crossfade the clips by a couple
frames this will help you down the line
when you need to blend and mix your
audio if some of these issues fall
directly into the dialogue though don't
panic i can tell you're panicking stop
stop freaking out see if you have more
than one take on any given shot or scene
and you know it's always good to have
multiple versions of a certain recording
while you're on set so keep that in mind
but what if i need to replace the line
and the speed of the new clip doesn't
match the previous ah well you can edit
that clip a little bit or you can use
automatic speech alignment if you're
using adobe audition
this is normally used for doing adr but
this tool allows you to manipulate each
take of dialogue to fit better with
what's happening on screen check it out
so chances are that you are working with
gopros dslrs or even cell phones they
don't have the best mics well phones
have decent mics but they don't have the
best mics generally on them and you want
to get the best sound possible on your
budget so you'll want to focus on the
dialogue and making that dialogue as
clear as possible to do that you'll use
an eq
it didn't stay long i didn't check my
watch well an eq is an equalizer it's a
tool that allows you to manipulate the
frequencies in your audio the most
common one that you and most people are
most likely familiar with is the
graphical eq it's got really good
graphics
no it's basically a curve that goes
across all the frequencies you can raise
and lower different points to help
emphasize what you need in your sound so
working with bad microphones you need to
make sure that the human voice is as
clear as possible and generally the
human voice is strongest in the 100 to
200 hertz range
so give that section a little bit of a
bump if you need to so that means you'll
be manipulating that area that range to
sound the most clear using the highs to
help the articulation the mids to help
strengthen and give it body and then you
can also remove the lows
and highs surrounding the dialogue or
voice to help get rid of any unnecessary
hums hisses or background sounds yeah
you did it
the one issue that will always affect
you no matter what microphone you use is
wind
[Music]
it's the low bassy rumble that is caused
by the air affecting the internals of
your microphone so how do you remove it
there's a few ways nico what's one way
all right so one simple way is to use
the eq again so look for those low tones
and dampen them as much as possible it's
very difficult to remove it from every
single shot but you'll likely find a
threshold where it feels comfortable
it's kind of working another tool you
can use to help remove wind noise is a
waveform editor the waveform editor
works very much like an eq except that
it gives you a visual representation of
every single frequency kind of like a
film strip so rather than raising and
lowering specific frequencies like an eq
you can actually select entire sections
of that frequency and delete specific
parts of it so it's a little more
effective when you need just one single
hum removed from a shot that's not
affecting your highs and mids just your
lows
you can also reduce noise by making a
noise print this is one of the features
you can also use in audition basically
it takes a segment of sound looks at
exactly what's happening in it and then
goes through and removes exactly what
you just fed it it's kind of like film
grain reduction with a camera except
it's for your ears anyways the further
you push this noise reduction the more
it will degrade your audio so just use
some nuance yeah so
part four
part four peaking audio
picking audio all right so there's a lot
of issues you can fix with these
solutions but sadly there are still some
that are pretty dang hard to fix
sometimes impossible actually but one of
them is peeking audio that's when you're
speaking too loudly into your microphone
so the funny part is you don't actually
have to yell to redline it just means
your mic levels are turned too high
so there's some filters that can kind of
help but not really it will always sound
funky and affect the audience's
experience the best solutions are what
we talked about find another take or
even try re-recording it
sorry about that one so now you know
some basics and fixing the occasional
problem in your sound you can relax and
trust it will turn out fine
wait but you don't want to just say we
can fix it in post
uh best the best problem is the one you
never have to deal with
so try to get like wind socks or dead
cats for your microphone not real dead
cats for cars and airplanes look into
what microphones are best for the scenes
and locations you're shooting it goes a
long way just like getting like the
right nv filters for your camera to help
stop down in the sunlight or getting the
right lens for the shot if you're using
a camera or recorder and mixer that can
mount multiple microphones try taking
advantage of that just like shooting
with two cameras for a single scene you
can actually use multiple microphones in
case one picks up a bad sound or one
messes up it's always good to have a
backup in fact sometimes people even use
the same microphone just going into two
lines and you can have one turned up and
one turned down so you get the whole
range on a lot of big movie sets they'll
usually have a wireless mic on every one
of the lead actors just like we're
wearing then depending on how much they
move around or where they move in the
scene they'll actually have one or two
more guys holding boom poles and shotgun
microphones across different points on
the set and even hide wireless mics
everywhere in tough to reach places
basically this prevents people from
missing any sound they need to get and
there's always a clean take gonna fill
you guys in on some interesting
technical stuff there's a few terms that
you guys might be familiar with such as
48 kilohertz sound or 44.1 kilohertz
sound you also might have heard 16-bit
audio or recording in 24-bit audio we're
going to quickly tell you guys what
those mean and how they affect your
audio when you hear the terms 48
kilohertz 48 kilohertz is a sample rate
effectively you're getting 48 000
samples per second or so it's like the
frame rate of your audio recording in a
way exactly it's the difference of
recording in 24 frames per second versus
60. they play over the same length of
time but that 60 frames per second is
buttery smooth and has tons of frames in
between
now bit depth on the other hand in a 16
bit sample you have 16 bits to represent
detail or the resolution of that sound
in 24 bits that's a much bigger number
to represent so many more values within
that sound from basically nothing to
everything dealing with adr and
re-recording lines is a pain in the
booty and so is dealing with wind noise
in post so just be very diligent to
prevent those problems from happening on
set and then later on when you're
editing it's going to be a breeze we
hope you guys learned a little bit here
and can maybe apply this to your own
piece and if you have any questions hit
us um on twitter at corridor digital or
send us an email or um
just uh
i don't know mail us something send a
raven send a raven digital pigeon send
your pigeons to cord or digital
and uh we will uh take those birds and
send them back
with like tips written on the tips a
little tip for the bird and the two
birds
[Music]